President Trump is pushing back against
reports that he ordered a White House
lawyer to fire Special Counsel Robert
Muller the New York Times reported the
president backed off his desire to fire
Muller but only after White House
layered on McGann's threatened to quit
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
the latest Darrel good morning good
morning what's noteworthy here is the
White House is not denying reports that
President Trump wanted to dismiss
special counsel Robert Muller last
summer instead the president's lawyer is
touting the administration's cooperation
with the investigation noting that 20
White House staffers have submitted to
voluntary interviews President Trump
returned from Switzerland to the White
House Friday evening huddled with his
communication staff on marine one he
then stopped only to address questions
from reporters about his Davos trip
neither the White House nor White House
Council Don McGann has issued a denial
of the report that mr. Trump wanted
special counsel Robert Muller fired CBS
News has confirmed last June President
Trump was angry about mullahs
investigation and raised concerns about
three possible conflicts of interest but
top White House advisors told mr. Trump
the conflicts of interest were not
grounds to fire mullah and that doing so
would be politically catastrophic
leading the president to drop the idea
before departing Davos the president
suggested the reports were false while
using his address to the World Economic
Forum to say the u.s. is open for
business but America first does not mean
America alone when the United States
grows so does the world his two-day
visit was also a chance to make up for
some diplomatic missteps in a meeting
with Rwanda as president he ignored
questions about his alleged use of a
vulgar term to refer to African nations
and in an interview with British
journalist Piers Morgan he was asked to
apologize for retweeting anti-muslim
content from a far-right group back in
November if you're telling me there's a
horrible people horrible racist people
horrible I would certainly apologize if
you'd like me to do that now President
Trump is expected to be interviewed by
special counsel mullah at some point
here in the next few weeks and earlier
the president told reporters that he is
quote looking forward to it Anthony
Errol Barnett at the White House thanks
Harold